hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast I'm your host Sean Carroll
several years ago when I wrote my book
The Big Picture its idea was to describe
and defend articulate naturalism right
the idea that the world is a fundamental
fundamentally natural thing no
Supernatural aspects or anything like
that and it's a weird task because you
have to both say well here's what we
have learned here's what we know but
also when it comes to the things we
don't yet know our best future
understandings or continue to going to
continue to be naturalistic and so
that's the case that I tried to make but
as you might expect within naturalism
people disagree with each other about
very important things so the particular
line I took was that the Universe the
physical world it just is you know it
exists it obeys its rules it has its
stuff that obeys the laws of physics and
so forth but it doesn't judge you it
doesn't care it doesn't evaluate await
you this is a moral anti-realist
position there is no set of rules out
there given to us by the universe that
helps us differentiate between right and
wrong good and bad things like that the
Universe in some sense doesn't care
about us human beings but that's not a
reason to be nihilistic or depressed or
anything like that because we human
beings care about we human beings so
it's not that there is no such thing as
right and wrong or meaning to life or
anything like that it's just that those
things are invented by human beings not
handed to us either by the universe or
by God or something outside the universe
so this particular point of view which
again is not necessarily completely
accepted there are people who disagree
fits in very well with the tradition not
just of naturalism but of humanism
humanism in some sense it's the very old
tradition of of emphasizing human beings
rather than the Divine or something like
that it's not necessarily atheistic you
can be religious and humanist but
there's a sort of natural Affinity if
you don't believe in God for putting
human beings at the center of of what
does matter you could also think that
human beings are insignificant in the
universe and that would make you kind of
non-humanist but a humanist says as far
as evaluating what matters to human
beings where that evaluation comes from
is also from human beings so it's a
fascinating history because it is not
how human beings were thinking thousands
of years ago we were in large extent
very supernaturalistic right human
beings 2000 years ago were pretty prone
to thinking that human beings themselves
were not the source of meaning and
mattering in the universe that idea had
to develop over the years through at
least in the west through the
Renaissance and the Enlightenment and so
forth in the East around the world
there's of course different paths that
were taken and the history is always
fascinating because these ideas don't
spring fully formed in uh their final
form they develop over time so today's
guest is Sarah Bakewell who is a
journalist writer scholar who thinks
about the history of these things in
fact if you liked our recent previous
talk on existentialism with Sky Cleary
Sarah is the author of a book called The
existentialist Cafe which you could
check out but her new book is called
humanly possible 700 years of humanist
free-thinking inquiry and hope so we
talk about precisely this history of
humanism going back to the 1300s in
Europe you know we touch a little bit
about the ancient Greeks in India China
and so forth but really her story starts
in the 1300s with literary humanism
patriarch boccaccio people like that
going up through a whole bunch of
different strains of thought from you
know Shakespeare to Voltaire uh Thomas
Paine and so forth up to the current day
Zora Neal Hurston Bertrand Russell
people like that science Darwin Huxley
how we should think about our place in
the universe if the idea of a place in
the universe is something that comes
particularly from human beings and where
is the place for humanism right now is
it important has it become the default
is it being overly ignored is there a
vital movement there
um what do we do if we think that
humanism is important or if we don't how
do we combat it that might be something
some of you are thinking right now but
anyway the history one way or the other
no matter where you come down on these
big issues is a fascinating one so let's
go
foreign
[Music]
Sarah Bakewell welcome to the mindscape
podcast thanks very much it's lovely to
be here so you've written a new book on
um the history of humanism why don't you
tell us the title of the book exactly
it's uh humanly possible the title and
the subtitle is 700 years of humanist
free thinking inquiry and hope I like
those it's I like the theme of optimism
that runs through the book as a
characteristic feature of humanism but
of course like this is one of those
interviews where the first question to
ask is just perfectly obvious namely
what do you mean humanism what is it
what is the definition of that I can
imagine people disputing different
possible definition it's very much
disputed and actually the first line of
the book is what is humanism and
um I'm actually quoting I and this is
quite a good way into talking about that
I think I'm quoting
um a comic novel by David knobs who's a
sort of English comic novelist best
known for the Fallen rise of Reginald
Perrin but this was
um a book which um called second from
last in the sack Grace where he was kind
of drawing out his own experiences of
being at school and he has this scene
where in this imaginary school
um some students decide to set up a
humanist society and they have their
inaugural meeting and of course in the
inaugural meeting of this is the first
question they ask what is humanism to
which it immediately degenerates into
total chaos because they all have
different ideas of what humanism is so
one of them says you know it's the
renaissance's attempt to escape from
medieval
scholasticism and the church and to
um go back to sort of literary studies
and uh and free thinking and then
another one says well no it's doesn't it
men like being kind and nice to people
and bandaging animals and things and
another one says well that's not
humanism humanism is trying to live
without belief in the Supernatural and
taking human life and human
connections to each other as the basis
of our morality and
um as to which the other one responds
but are you saying that it's not good to
bandage animals and look after people
and things and it just goes on but the
thing is they've actually Nails all of
the main definitions of humanism there
and my starting point is rather than
saying well no humanism is not bad it's
this I prefer to say well actually it's
all of those things and they are all
brought together by the word human
that's at the center of the word
humanism so you have for example one of
the the meanings that is very familiar
especially in the English-speaking World
in general is this idea of living
without
um the dogmas of religion and probably
without religious Faith sure but at
least without putting that centrally and
um very much foregrounding Human
Relationships moral obligation to each
other a sense of community and things
like that is the basis of our morality
but of course there's this whole I mean
at The Other Extreme of quite a range of
meanings it was used through much of
History
um of this sort of Europe from really
late medieval times through what we the
early modern era or the Renaissance we
might call it to
um I mean people who specialized in well
the humanities and we still recall
specialists in the humanities humanists
um they are the people who specialize in
the human studies so that means
literature the Arts culture history the
historical understanding of things a
whole huge range of stuff to do with
human culture and again that it just has
the sense of human at the center of it
so I think there's a fantastic range and
I really believe in at least for me in
my book in trying to be inclusive in the
all these definitions to try and take
the broadest most connected sense of
humanism that I can but there is still a
core there's definitely a core at the
heart of it and it's there in the words
human so you're not here to tell us what
the once and for all right definition is
so much as to be inclusive and
ecumenical about you know the positive
aspects of all these definitions I'm
definitely looking for a rich sense I
think all these meanings of humanism can
enrich each other and
um and really lead us to think about
well what is the
um idea of the distinctively human
cultural or ethical realm which I think
he all these kinds of humanism have in
common that they foreground that so
there's the physical world of course
there's the world that is studied by
science there's uh this sort of physical
reality of which we're apart with that
undeniably and them may or may not be
According to some people's beliefs a
um purely spiritual realm a realm of
gods and the Transcendent abstractions
perhaps and then there's the realm of
culture language you know songs dances
stories
um the many ways in which we respond to
each other educate each other entertain
each other uh have moral obligations to
each other the entire realm of culture
and humanists are definitely I think
United by a real interest in that realm
in in all kinds of ways and uh so yes I
it only connect is my motto it's kind of
where I try to look for connections
because I think that's
um for me at least I find that so
interesting I think there's definitely
been maybe a slight shift in the
immediate connotation of the word when
we think about Renaissance humanists it
was more about thinking about human
beings uh writing fiction and stories
about them uh you know Center centering
The Human Experience and maybe today
there's more of a secularism atheism
agnosticism
um implication that comes along
well really what I'm trying to do is to
is to draw the connections between some
of those things and
um in fact you know it's even more the
sort of the earliest meaning of the word
in Italian was literally just based on
those who teach and study the human
studies and what that meant actually was
quite specific it was things like
grammar
um eloquence rhetoric it was it was
drawing on the classical Greek and Roman
sense of what you needed for public life
and to be a good person and passing that
down the generations of the so it of
course it's come a very long way since
since that meaning but but each step of
that those Transformations I think is is
connected so for example those people
although they were fascinated by the
humanities and by rhetoric eloquence and
all the rest of it they were also
fascinated by the idea of moral
um Revival on the basis of these ancient
sources of finding a better way to
manage Society finding a better way for
each of us to govern ourselves in our
relationships with our communities with
our world
um so the the moral meaning the literary
if you like meaning and by extension I
think the the secular meaning is there
um of course they were certainly not
unbelievers most of those people through
most of European history because that
was very rare I mean to be an absolutely
overt outspoken spoken direct atheist
was extremely rare and there's a lot of
debates about you know how rare it
really was but
um but the emphasis was on the
um the human world the way in which we
manage society as I say you know all of
those sort of political social and
communicative skills so literature
eloquence and things like that not on
theology which tended to be very much
set apart in fact it was actually
um people would say well I just speak of
human things and I leave Divine things
to the theologians so there was that
separation of Realms even then I can I
can relate one tiny relevant story here
which is that my wife Jennifer Willett
uh is a winner of the humanists of the
Year award the American humanist
Association and when she got the notice
uh she said like maybe they mean you to
me because I'm the more outspoken you
know atheist secularist but I thought it
was brilliant because her life's work
has been devoted to writing about
science but in a way that centers human
beings and tells stories and relates it
to us and I thought that was an ideal
example of humanism in action so I
thought those are brilliant it is
absolutely I mean I think and you know
that's great that she she got that award
and that sounds like a very very good
reason for giving it I mean although I
imagine the same thing could be said of
you as well that you I know you could
great science communicate to science
philosophy I think
um I'd like to see that connection too
because as I say on the one hand there's
you know you've got the realm of
Theology and the realm of the human but
the other great division in those kind
of three parts is this idea of the realm
of the physical world the realm of
Science and I think sometimes we're
encouraged to think that scientific
thought is entirely set apart from Human
feelings human thought human responses
to the world ethics values all of that
um and I mean I don't think it is I'm
not a relativist when it comes to
science consent so I don't feel like
scientific method is somehow purely
subjective I think that's I really don't
agree with that but but I think that um
our desire to use scientific method to
explore the world to explore the nature
of the universe is itself very much a
part of our Humanity what we are as
human beings
um is is deeply bound up with our
interest in science and our scientific
instincts if you like so I love to see
those potential gulps being bridged and
that so yeah brilliant I I do want to
get to the actual history here but uh
maybe maybe one more clarifying question
would be given all these wonderfully
good aspects of humanism as you've laid
them out who would ever not be a human
what does it mean to who's the who's the
other side who are the anti-humanists
both early and maybe today
anti-humanists and always have been and
it's equally hard to Define what that
means too because it does I mean it
sounds like self-evidently a bad thing
and it's not it may not be because
actually quite often those might be
people who are reminding us not to be
too Vain about ourselves not to be too
carried away on saying humans are
wonderful which is something I don't
think humanists do usually say but there
have been some who have expressed
themselves in those terms you know human
is how how what a piece of work is man
you know how how excellent we are
um well you know anti-humanists are
there to say hang on a minute
are you sure about that yeah and um
right I think also they um they do sort
of remind
um us of the of the less rational parts
that you know we can't pride ourselves
on being too rational too good at
getting on with each other in society
let's you know remember that there are
all these bad things that happen
um and that we do and so I think there's
a really useful sort of constant
response and interrelationship between
humanism and anti-humanism I think they
they naturally tend to call each other
up because as soon as somebody says
anything strongly humanistic or
anti-humanistic it naturally calls up a
response but this is all parts of what
we always do as human beings which is
thinking about ourselves trying to
figure out what kind of creatures we are
and how we should be living in this
world
um so yeah definitely I think you could
never have one without the other and
some humanists are more optimistic than
others some are maybe naive so this is
something that again the anti-humanists
are there to remind us not to be naive
um but
um but not all you know a lot of
humanists have had a much more nuanced
uh sense and and to me the my my great
case of that and we might be jumping
ahead of any kind of chronological
sequencies but um but is Michelle de
montaigne who has I've written a book
about him before he's a great uh
somebody I find endlessly fascinating as
a writer of 16th century essayist he was
certainly a humanist in all kinds of
ways there's a literally somebody who
read deeply in in the literature of
classical and contemporary authors who
considered what he read
um reinvented it kind of for his world
and
um and he was a humanist in that he was
fascinated by human life by his own
human character he wrote about us all
the time but he is also
um he wrote pages and pages and pages on
uh how we shouldn't get up ourselves
basically because we are
dude terrible stupid things all the time
and the other animals are much better at
um all kinds of things than we are and
he draws on Plutarch who who assembled a
great mass of stories of animals it
builds better
birds build nests they do a much better
job of it than we ever do within our
buildings and things like that so so
Montana is somebody who to my mind sums
up that those two exactly that tension
between humanism and anti-humanism the
tension between he is a humanist but
he's not always an optimistic one and
his employer gives a much more nuanced
feeling
and as you said you know especially back
in those days to be a humanist was not
to be an atheist uh in the way that we
would recognize it right now but but you
also mentioned that there is a strain in
religious thought maybe not all
religions or whatever but there's a kind
of religious thought that is deeply
anti-humanist where they say the
fundamental nature of humans is to be
fallen is to be Sinners is to be falling
short and we need to look outside
Humanity for salvation right I mean am I
correct in saying that that is more or
less unambiguously not what a humanist
would want yeah I think that's pretty
safe to say that's not a humanist View
and
um William James who wrote a great
varieties of religious experience
analyzing religion loss of it from the
psychological point of view said
um that this for him this is this basic
structure of religion first it tells us
that there's something wrong with us
deeply wrong with us there then it tells
us that this is the way to fix it and it
holds up the religious well Dogma or
consolation or whatever you want to call
it or
um appeal to a higher authority
um I mean I it may I make I'm kind of
unsure myself whether would it really be
right to say that all religion has that
I'm not sure that I would say that but
you can certainly find it in in
Christianity of course if you go back to
Saint Augustine he invented the concept
of original sin and it's certainly their
own original sin I mean that's what
original sin is even newborn babies are
born Ron their needs Redemption from the
Jesus Christ and uh and and from God
um I think that's you know it's religion
is that's such a blanket term there is
so much going on in religion there is a
humanist strand in religion a lot of
people argue quite strongly for that
others argue that no that's kind of you
know you can't really see that much
humanism in religion and it's a bit of
an abuse at the time I don't agree with
it with either extreme you know I think
that religion tends towards a kind of
more humanist strand when it really
focuses on human well-being and life
here on Earth amongst each other and
what we can do for each other rather
than
um this idea that something terribly
wrong and that the main thing we have to
do is pray to be redeemed from it
okay good with all of that background
out of the way thank you very much
um you know I'm sure I don't know
whether you want to
um elaborate but I'm sure there were
precursors to what we think of as
humanism in ancient Greece in ancient
China or India or or elsewhere in the
world but arguably your story starts in
the 1300s in Italy and so how did it
start why did it start what were they
reacting again I kind of started it
there because it has to start somewhere
and it is quite a traditional place to
start telling the story of humanism
um and with good reason because
um there was all sorts of what we could
certainly regard as humanist activity
going on before that well through the
previous centuries but but what really
changes in the 1300s among a small group
of people is they start explicitly
explicitly thinking of themselves as
recovering from some kind of Dark Age a
term which they basically coin in order
to renew the modern Worlds by reaching
back to the lost or half lost or not
quite lost writings of the Ancients
meaning mostly Latin authors and also
Greek authors which they had great
difficulty in Reading still because very
few people could read Greek but they
explicitly begins so I'm really talking
about
um the sort of the people that stand out
in this story are uh petroch we always
call him an English Francesco who was
um born in Italy and his family were
sort of refugees from Florence uh due to
political upheavals there uh they he
actually grew up in Avignon or just near
Avignon in France where they had to flee
to
um and he devoted his life to literature
which he had to battle for a little bit
because uh his father who was basically
a nursery expected is his son to follow
into the legal world he didn't want to
do that he wanted to read and write and
collect books and that's exactly what he
managed to do all his life slowly
because some some things never change
the uh I know children like living up to
their expectations of their parents was
never going to go away that's it I mean
you can rebel by sort of going out since
and taking drugs or getting drunk or
something or you can rebel by going out
and buying manuscripts of Cicero
which is what pet shop did and
um he managed to make quite a good life
for himself by
um really working for patrons which were
sometimes involved with the church
sometimes uh just sort of you know
private nobility who really funded his
activities so he got to spend his time
collecting what he could find and this
meant often going around monasteries
which did have fantastic collections of
books often include
secular works from the ancient world or
at least copied and handed down by
generations of copies from the ancient
world and um so Petra sort of collected
these studied them edited them began all
again is back to the humanities all the
things that we now associate with the
humanities this uh close work on texts
and uh and then generally literary and
moral study and political so and the
other one of that time that I do find a
very sort of fascinating character is um
Giovanni bocatra who was a friend became
a friend of Petra slightly younger
generation and he too did the same thing
going around monasteries digging up
these manuscripts or you know sort of
lagging his way into getting hold of
them doing copies of them sharing them
with with friends and with pet shop it
was kind of a bit of an industry you
know it's a tremendous energy that they
put into it but as I say they they
really saw themselves as they're
starting a new beginning and then that
makes them quite a good point to start
in looking at that
story of humans but they were also
writers themselves they weren't just
collecting old manuscripts so they were
very much they were starting something
new very much so they wrote in almost
every genre imaginable I mean petrock is
remembered particularly for his sonnets
in poetry but he wrote other kinds of
poetry and lots of prayers and really my
favorite
um writings of his were his letters
to his friends which he then led a
certain point in his life decided to
collect and assemble into a volume and
copy it out and improve on a little bit
quite a lot of uh you know polishing up
went on yeah and then he made that into
a sort of a collection which he then
distributed that among his friends for
their enjoyment and interest
um full of details of his life his world
his concerns some of the letters were
addressed to the ancient authors that he
loved so he'd write to them quite
familiarly as if they were friends as
well and sort of tell them off a bit you
know for doing things that they
shouldn't have
um and boccacho also wrote a very wide
range of stuff we remember him mainly
for the de Cameron which is this 100
Tales
um of a tremendous range again you know
a lot of them are quite boardy and just
good fun and
um romps really and others are really
quite serious and they meant to be taken
as moral lessons so he's showing off the
range of what he can do
and so what made uh those two figures
and their contemporaries specifically
humanist in Europe well it is it's the
way that they saw themselves as
um recovering the past and through these
manuscripts this manuscript hunting this
reading of the ancient authors
recovering the past and then Reinventing
it reinvigorating it for a new
generation so there was there was
certainly that sense of Hope in the
future not much hope in their present it
was very difficult to because they lived
in a very difficult time the the 14th
century was really a terrible time in in
much of Europe not least because the
plague spread through all those areas in
the middle of their lives and uh it was
devastating absolutely devastating to
people's sense of of security in life as
well as just literally devastating to
many cities and populations so
um tough times but they you know and
they saw themselves as using the power
of literature the power of these ancient
Arts of good government and good
speaking good writing beautiful
eloquence in writing and speech using
those as a as a way of renewing uh human
life
it's interesting that you mentioned the
play because it obviously was you know
on everyone's mind at the time and and
whenever we talk about Grand historical
shifts in how people think and talk and
and what have you I'm I'm fascinated by
do the ideas themselves lead to these
shifts or their external factors that
nudge them along I mean in the case of
the 1300s on the one hand it's the end
of the Dark Ages the beginning of the
Renaissance at the other hand it's the
end of the Islamic golden age uh in a
world where exactly the Islamic world
was tightly interacting with the
European world at the time so do you
give credit mostly to you know the
thinkers and their ideas here or their
external conditions that help explain
why it was then and there I think it's
tremendously complex and I also think
that's the point that you're making is
also absolutely essential it's a
reminder that this I whole idea of the
being a dark ages or some sort of you
know terrible time before the
Renaissance brought light to anything is
a very eurocentric idea because it only
makes sense from the point of view of
mainly of Western Europe
um so and in fact it you know it's not
an idea that really stands up to a lot
of scrutiny as as is always the case
with these pretty sweeping
characterizations of particular eras as
being one thing or another because
they're always vastly more complex in
the the chain of cause and effect the
relationships of different cultures to
each other across fertilization of
cultures
um all of this was was going on and
um was very it was definitely no one
simple story
um you know you don't I mean in a way I
sort of take Petra mochacho in their own
sense of themselves but not uncritically
you know I think that uh we can look at
them under all sorts of different lights
and say a whole loads of factors that
went into what made up their world
it does seem that one little bit of
Technology was absolutely crucial was
simply books right I mean we had books
for a long time but the idea of sharing
texts back and forth was you know it's
not it was wasn't the their version of
social media but it did it was
absolutely necessary to make these
shifts happen even more specifically a
crucial thing was they arrival of paper
technology in Europe they'd had it of
course in China for much longer
um before that they had to use parchment
made from
um you know calf skin and the skin of
other animals tremendously expensive and
labor intensive too
um to manufacture I mean you could
hardly call it landfill it was terribly
painstaking process and of course that
material was so valuable that quite
often in order to have a fresh bit of
parchment for writing or copying some
new to text in the monasteries in their
scriptoria they would
scrub off an old piece of writing in
order to get themselves a piece of
parchment that they could reuse and that
process certainly contributed to our
loss of quite a few tanks especially if
they felt that they wanted to write
something sacred and that it was better
to scrub off an old bit of uh something
from the classical World pre-christian
which didn't mention you know he wasn't
in line with it right um I think that
that can be exaggerated in the sense of
yeah these monasteries did also actually
preserve those pre-christian texts and
um often did a very good job of it but
you know definitely yeah there was an
element of uh we desperately needed
parchment which of these precious things
are we going to erase in order to have
it so paper was of course paper was
brilliant it was much much cheaper and
more readily available
and when these first stirrings of
humanism arose uh we're in a very deeply
religious culture at the time was there
backlash or did people even realize that
oh this was going to go bad places in
terms of the established uh religious
life never because it usually it wasn't
really
um any kind of direct challenge to
Christianity at all I mean it was taking
place a lot of these people worked for
the church they were parts of the
especially in Rome but also elsewhere
they often were associated in some way
they often had taken orders in in one
way though because the church was such a
center of intellectual activity it
wasn't really much choice but they
probably you know you don't get the
sense that they did it particularly
reluctantly I mean it just wasn't there
but there are some exceptions where
people did write things which
antagonized the church greatly or
challenged the church's claim to
Authority see and one of my favorite of
the humanists this is into the 15th
century now so it's uh later than
Patrick was Lorenzo Vala who wrote a
fantastic total
um takedown of this bogus document that
was called the Donation of Constantine
which supposedly recorded this moment
when the emperor Constantine
um signed a document
bequeathing to the Pope's the pope and
all their successes control over the
whole of the Western Empire really Italy
and all sorts of other lands all over
Western Europe
um and in fact it was a total
fabrication it's had been you know put
together
um years after it was supposed to be and
valder used this humanistic skills to
expose the fraud he
um particularly used he was a philology
purchase so he was an expert in
the Latin and also Greek his Greek was
very good
um but he used his knowledge of Latin
not just as a Timeless thing but Latin
is there's a language that had evolved
and been used differently in later
Medieval Times from the way that it had
been used in early
Medieval Times in the fourth century
when it was supposedly written
um to point out that it couldn't
possibly have been written then because
the words that we use just weren't they
weren't used at that time and there were
all sorts of clues in the text which he
pointed out saying well this document is
not what it's claimed to be and that
therefore of course was a big challenge
to the church's claim over all the
territory that it said it has been
basically bequeathed forever
so I mean in some sense can we look at
that as almost a precursor to science
and as sort of a new way of thinking in
the sense that it's not pure logic or
rationalism in the old sense nor is it
Revelation or anything like that it's
looking at the evidence
comparing different hypotheses and
seeing yeah it's definitely using those
tools and it's kind of using but it's
using literary tools so it's using
knowledge of language cultural tools
um more than study of the natural worlds
but certainly it's it's using them in a
way that points out
um contradictions it points out I think
that I mean across medieval Scholastic
intellectuals did they did point out
contradictions they did have a very good
knowledge of uh language what's new is
this sense of a historical way of
looking at
um what has come down to us so thinking
historically thinking this text has come
from somewhere and what has gone into it
how was it made who made it and why and
we're seeing really the beginning almost
less of science I'd say we're seeing
seeing the real beginning of history of
historians in the modern sense and
um certainly of that kind of critical
history that's um that history that
investigates the evidence and
foregrounds the evidence and then asks
well what is the hypothesis here what's
likely what's not likely I'm very happy
to count history as a subset of science
so that's that's me but it also points
to another kind of big deal at that time
you've already mentioned books and paper
but also education reform right
different ways of uh organizing the
curriculum and different ways of
teaching things the birth of the
University may be part of this whole
story yeah again that sort of goes back
to in well earlier an era that's for
sure
um the university but and also of course
Very Much Drew on the Arabic world that
was really where that began
um but it's what's new again in the
education is is this idea of
um being educated for the good life
being educated for to be a good human
being to be a
um a fully uh realized human being and
somebody who's able to take up their
places in society because of course it
was mostly the elite and almost entirely
men who were being educated in this way
um and they were being educated to to
become wise princes and heads of
um whatever it was that they were going
to be called on to do so perhaps working
in the city Administration
um it's actually very similar to the uh
the training of the Civil Service
people that was going that went on in
much earlier time in China which is a
lot of confusion writing is um is very
much focused on you know how do you
learn it's not just about learning the
various rules and and how to use the
bureaucratic documents and although that
was a large part of their training went
on for years and years and years it's
about
um how do you become a good person
because if you're a good ruler other
people the the people below you sort of
in the community will will want to
emulate you and they'll become better
and everybody will be better off and
um you know cultivating Humanity they
had this word uh Rin which means
Humanity conscience being a good person
is a there's a huge range of meanings in
in that word and there's really the same
thing
um could be found in a lot of the
writings of the humanists of the
Renaissance and May in turn are drawing
on the uh writings of the Roman World
which also stressed and the Greeks as
well who also stressed virtue being a
good person so this becomes at the
center of Education
um public life and
Humanity human virtue at the risk of
maybe being parochial and too much
caught up in my own time is there a
worry that we're losing that conception
of Education that uh modern universities
and high schools for that matter are
focused on giving technical skills to
students and less focused on turning
them into good human beings well
definitely where we start to see that
concern
um absolutely sort of being expressed
all over the place is in the 19th
century
um and even actually the late 18th
um you start getting philosophers of
education and public commentators of All
Sorts saying we're just teaching skills
we're just teaching
um we're teaching people try training
them for jobs and careers maybe but it's
in a very fragmented way there's no what
we're not doing is train training people
to be whole human beings and they're
fascinated by wholeness in that time
like complete fulfillment development
wholeness as a human being that's what
education should be doing primarily
um and also doing it the made a fair bit
of Freedom that the students should it
should come from within them there
shouldn't just be drummed in with skills
and skill sets and bits of knowledge
they should be encouraged to the job of
an educator is to literally the meaning
of educate is to draw out to lead out
what's in the student you know what's in
the person
um as they develop it's eh
which is like sort of dual chair
actually funnily enough in Italian it's
that same meaning which means you know
to um to lead and you're sort of leading
out so you're helping your leading out
what's in the student so that I knew
sort of concern about
um you know fragmentary education or
education that is simply skills based
simply about education for a purpose of
training out people who can do
whatever's required of them in society
rather than
encouraging people as they grow up to
develop into fully realized human beings
fully integrated human beings rich with
a rich interior life as well and and and
and Abel's play a really valuable role
in society that became the the new ideal
and I think but that was drawing on the
ideas of the earlier humanists so
there's a real chain of
um inspiration going between those those
different centuries we're definitely
still talking about the same issues
today absolutely and as always there's
no real right answer because I mean
there are criticisms that could be made
of this Renaissance idea of the
humanistic education because for
starters it was definitely for an elite
who were expected to govern yeah well I
mean you know we actually see quite that
is still going on in the modern world I
mean there's this sort of ox there's a
kind of Oxford uh University
um path that is a bit Infamous here in
the UK because it's this is where so
many
um in the government and uh often
perhaps people who are sort of
maintaining they have those skills they
have a certain polish they can sling
around Latin quotations
um but do they how much do they really
know about the struggles of ordinary
people so there's a there's a there's
still that tension there's still that
debate that's that's going through to do
to do with elitism which is to do with
the question of elitism and related to
that is again going back to that
Renaissance education very few women got
it there were a few
um Queen Elizabeth the first was a prime
example of that so she's pretty good
yeah
yeah she got a great education she also
you know was um kind of insisted on it
herself I think but she did get a good
education now that was actually largely
because she was destined to govern she
was expecting to govern so she needed
that training and how to do it so yeah
yeah I mean this woman didn't have that
at all because they were they were not
expected to have any kind of public life
they were expected to live a purely
private life in the family
this is in danger of being a whole other
podcast uh topic but it's so fascinating
to me I don't want to let it go quite
yet I mean as you're pointing out the
ideal of a humanistic education uh a
full one a broad one
um it's very interesting because I never
really never really dwelled on the fact
that it was meant for prospective
leaders right it's obviously for an
elite it was for a tiny number of people
and in particular the ones who were
going to be leaders and so that was the
justification for why you would have
this broad education and today we have
more of an ideal of universal education
uh and we put less emphasis on the
broadly humanistic aspects of it but so
so maybe there's a gap there that uh
remains to be filled where people make
the strong argument for why every person
deserves a broad humanistic education
yeah and so another thing I'd add to
that is that it didn't really include
anything that we would call in science
it didn't include it arguably and I
think this has been argued they got a
more kind of scientific education in
under medieval scholasticism than they
did under the humanistic ideal because
that was very focused on good government
good literary skills and all the rest of
it there really wasn't about science at
all of course science as we know it now
didn't exist yet but yeah there wasn't
there wasn't what we would Now call
science really just was pretty absent
and it was in the 19th century again
where Educators started to say well
maybe it's more useful the most
important thing is to give everybody a
good grounding in scientific thought and
that means not just the actual you know
knowledge of science but how to think
yeah scientifically how to ask questions
scientifically how to test hypotheses
how to
um you know that's those are great
thinking skills and some of them reacted
against that humanistic education by
saying well it's just to I mean what's
the point of learning Latin and ancient
Greek when you could be learning about
the physical world that's all around us
and of course I mean I think as always
I'm inclined to say well why can't we
have it all yeah we're both here
okay uh sorry for that digression but I
do think it it's important but let's uh
since we're trying to squeeze many
centuries of human development into a
tiny amount of time
um take us from the Renaissance to the
enlightenment which when I was a kid I
always used to think that they were the
same thing but they're clearly very very
different things
um but the the humanist strand continues
through there it does and this at home
kind of Meandering I mean this there's a
there are periods between those two
which are very interesting as well but I
do think it's it's I do quite sort of I
think jumping to the enlightenment is
not a bad idea because that's when you
start to see certainly you start to see
the rise of scientific thinking
um so we're talking 18th century there's
a kind of long Enlightenment that's that
sometimes is traced back to the 17th
century
um and various philosophers and
scientists of course very much that
we're beginning to you know
revolutionize science in that era but
the height of it was the 18th century
and one strand is is using reason using
scientific method being having a great
belief in the power of that
um but the thing that I think is
specifically humanistic about that is
that it's having a belief in the power
of that to improve human lives to
improve human well-being and the fact
that they wanted to foreground that
question of human well-being so
um one of the figures that leaps out in
that is is Voltaire a great figure of
the Enlightenment who
um really believed that
um it's we should do everything that
that we can to
um instead of sort of trying to find
ways of justifying by reference to some
Divine principle
um the fact of human suffering
um we should actually do what we can too
because you can never banish human
suffering at all but
um to reduce it and to Minima to make it
a little bit less widespread than it is
or to provide ways
um of sort of well yeah just making the
be less suffering he um was very uh
veensely very uh shocked by the
um earthquake this is you know sort of
the earthquake in Lisbon of 1755 which
um shocked a lot of people around you
European government physically yeah of
course but uh I mean it actually was
felt as far afield as like Sweden and
Scotland they could they can feel this
earthquake from Portugal of course the
destruction in Lisbon and around it was
absolutely terrific and so many people
died either instantly or because of the
fires and uh just Civic breakdown that
that followed
um Voltaire was wrote several things
most famously condeed his little
um it's a sort of fable but um he also
wrote a poem about it and he wrote
entries in his philosophical dictionary
about uh about this question of when
terrible things happen and he took aim
at this
justification that was um put forward by
the philosopher leibniz but you know it
was sort of cited by in other contexts
as well this idea that
um well it's often quoted as all always
for the best and the best in the best of
all possible Worlds the idea behind it
was that well clearly god
um he could have made they to not be an
earthquake he didn't but since God has
benevolent and since you know I'm sure
he would have stopped it if he could
clearly he can't clearly there's some
very good reason that only God knows
about which means that a world in which
that earthquake didn't happen would be
somehow worse and far be it through mass
as mere human beings to
um dispute that you know clearly
something's going on that's far above us
and we couldn't bust the instance so
it's this
um justifying the ways of God to man
it's this referring of the we should we
just have to accept we just have to
refer it upwards when I mean Voltaire
was very annoyed by that attitude
because he said well whether that's true
or not first of all we've got a perfect
right to be whale Our Fate and and
complain and and gnash our teeth that
that the sufferings that we undergo in
life
um then secondly why not actually do
something practical to make it
um just a yeah less likely to happen
less disruptive when these things happen
we can't stop earthquakes but
um as we've improved on vastly since
then there's a lot that can be done to
bills to a higher quality so that
buildings don't fall down so much
um to provide better Civic management
actually which is vital of course in the
aftermath of disaster and since long
after Voltaire we've sort of developed a
certain ability to see earthquakes
coming as we know none of this works um
always at still horror absolute Horrors
happen
um but it was later called meliorism
um this actually wasn't a term of
voltaires or anything it was apparently
the novelist George Eliot was the first
or possibly the second actually to use
to be quoted as using this to him it
just means we can make things a bit
better you know we can't solve we can't
make a perfect world we can't solve
everything we can use our Ingenuity our
technology our political skills our
management of situations our ability to
predict things we can use those to make
things a little bit better and I think
that idea is to me is one of the it's
the humanist idea at the heart of a lot
of what happened in the enlightenment so
the enlightenment's often been seen
largely in terms of people adulating the
idea of reason and being besotted by the
idea that we can be reasonable but I
think a lot of Enlightenment thinkers
actually we're just saying let's just
try to be more reasonable than we
currently are because it improves human
life if we do I like the idea that
plagues and earthquakes play such a
large role in the flourishing of
humanism uh throughout history but yeah
so it's supposed to be such a cheerful
philosophy it's supposed to it's just a
chapter of disaster but it actually it
it makes sense upon reflection because I
would take part of humanism to sort of
like you just said accept the
responsibility of trying to make things
better you know an anti-humanist or
non-humanist philosophy can kind of
offload that to if not explicitly God to
Destiny to Providence to fate or
whatever it is whereas a humanist has
got to say well look there's Randomness
but we still have to do the best we can
in the face of that that's absolutely
right that idea of responsibility taking
responsibility for ourselves
collectively and individually I mean you
know that there are disasters there will
always be disasters but it's really up
to us to try and respond to these in in
the way that's that's as helpful as
possible
um you can sort of start to see the
connections with the the world view that
doesn't put divine order at the center
of things the world view that starts to
put human not only well-being but also
actually human decision making human
um action and responsible choices at the
heart of things instead from our point
of view
um the you know the realm in which some
sort of divine battle between God or
Satan for example might be going on is
like well maybe it is maybe it isn't
this really doesn't have much to do with
us on today's day basis we have to
um think about ways to build better
buildings so they don't pull down so
yeah and this was the
period when you said earlier you know
about the Renaissance humanists none of
them were loudly explicitly atheists but
now in the 18th century we begin to get
some loud explicit atheists yeah
Voltaire was not one as far as I can
tell that's right and and you you give a
lot of prominence to David Hume one of
my favorite philosophers and he was I
yeah yeah you referred to him as
merciless but there's a there's a an
anecdote I'm not I'm not sure if it's
true or not of uh Hume visiting the
salons of Paris and and saying something
like uh none of us here is is you know
explicitly atheist and and all of his
hosts are like no we all are except for
you except for you well how did they
just transition happen yeah there was a
um a philosophy that came to be called
deism
um which provided a very good cover for
any atheist who wanted to cover because
it basically said exactly that that
um you know there probably is a God
we're not saying there's not a God you
know this yeah the deity
um but he just he or it or whatever
doesn't enter into everyday human life
there's no direct everything in natural
world and in our lives goes on
separately from that and so of course if
you're an atheist but you don't want to
say so because being explicitly atheist
was quite dangerous still I really was
very dangerous um so I could get you
into all sorts of trouble if you
directly challenge the idea of the being
a god at all but you could just set that
aside and then go on to talk about human
life as if God had everything connected
with with that sort of transcendent
realm was completely irrelevant of
course I I don't think that all of the
people I think I was Deus were simply
using it as a cover the problem is that
we just can't really know it's terribly
difficult to know because obviously if
they didn't record that in their
writings then you know they're not going
to write down on a piece of paper and
well I'm pretending to be a deist but
really I'm an atheist or very very
rarely yeah um but there are some where
we we do have a pretty good inkling I
mean
um another great Enlightenment
philosopher and thinker
um didro denidro was probably I mean it
gives quite a lot of sign of probably
being an atheist
um he had to bury or leave unpublished a
lot of his writings where that was
suggested and as I say David Hugh you
know did make it the belt was explicit
as you could um but even then not
entirely but you know he was known in he
lived in Edinburgh he was known as the
great Infidel and the great atheist so
he he had a reputation but there was uh
nevertheless a looming blind spot which
of course you're going to talk about
which is that even the people who would
have identified as humanists would
narrowly Define humanity the part of
humanity that deserves the right and
respect the rights and respect uh that
everyone should get white male certain
age certain proclivities
Etc and you know it took people who were
not in those categories to raise their
hand and say wait a minute you know
we're human beings too that's an
important uh story in the history of
human absolutely
yeah and that um is I mean the
enlightenment is particularly uh
ambiguous in that regard because some of
the Apparently most
um critically minded and rational and uh
you know sort of you would expect better
off than frankly um Enlightenment
thinkers were perfectly capable of
saying that of course this didn't apply
to and then there's a whole list of you
know sort of colonized peoples or
um people of African origin or anybody
basically who wasn't uh of European
origin
um and of course women are the great
just half the human race is absolutely
left out of it for much of it but what
you begin to see is people who are say
black women for example starting to say
well there's us okay you know we're
human too yeah um but often they use and
where I find it particularly interesting
is where they use the some of the tools
of humanistic thought or thought
precisely too
think critically about the received idea
that women don't really count and to
start to to investigate that and to
query it and they do it on the basis of
a lot of humanistic philosophy so
somebody like Mary Wollstonecraft author
of indication of the rights of women in
late 18th century
um used the kind of the same critical
thinking about you know how did things
come to be this way that for example I
was talking about a lot of Enzo Valle
who who used the sort of historical
thought and she does the same it's like
well if you might think that women seem
a bit vapid and they are uneducated and
they're they lack confidence well think
about why are they uneducated it's
because you haven't given them an
education you know why do they lack
confidence is because they're constantly
told that they should be modest and
um retiring and that they shouldn't
Express their opinions and so starting
to think at a kind of
genealogical way or a historical way
about you know why is this so there's
that and another humanistic strand I
think is starting to appeal to an idea
of there being something kind of I mean
the phrase of dignity is often used in
the context of
um the Dignity of of Human Rights or the
Dignity of of human Essence somehow that
we all all of us have
um an essential uh dignity and a central
Humanity which for all however diverse
are many aspects of our lives are
there's also something that we all share
which is our humanity and
um nobody should be seen as having any
less of that than anybody else and um so
then you sort of start to see this
argument coming which will end with
things like the Declaration of Human
Rights where that's a central idea in
the mid-20th century
um but it's feminists and about all
kinds of other voices are starting to
come in and say
um there is an essential Humanity so you
can't Mary Wollstonecraft says you can't
talk about the being particularly female
virtues for example in in male and and
then not even male virtues but kind of
human virtues yes human virtues and then
there's the particular ones that women
are supposed to have which just happen
to be all very negative so it's all like
modesty
um you know sort of Silence
um not talking too much yeah I'll arrest
me
um but there are you know she says it's
not we all have or should have human
virtues we should all be educated to
have human radio if you're human beings
your virtues are human virtues and the
total Sam of of the virtues of humanity
include the traditional female ones and
the traditional male ones so it's um
this is a these are all very humanistic
concerns because humanists had always
been very interested in the question of
what makes a good human being what is it
to be virtuous what
um what's needed in the public realm in
terms of
training people to be good training
people to be completely to be
knowledgeable to be eloquent to be able
to take part in decision making in
society all of these things are starting
to be brought up in the context of
um not being exclusive so there's less
and less of the idea of the human is
something exclusive and um and more
inclusive it's certainly not a
straightforward story because there's
tremendous amount of backwards and
forwards this this can just confusions
there's inconsistencies you get somebody
might be very good at arguing for for
women but actually hopeless on questions
of race and but you know so oh yeah it's
a tremendously complicated process
um and you know it's not just like one
smooth progress that's for sure but what
is being seen as a is a great sort of
diversifying of of the whole humanist
picture which is still going on today
because we're still very much of course
this is a a never-ending
um doll you know it's not there is
there's no point where you can say well
we've arrived we've sourced out the
whole problem of excusion I mean of
course not you know one of the stories
in your book that I really liked uh
which was not quite contemporary but I
think anything that happens after I'm
born is is the modern world so um Mary
Whitehouse was a you know conservative
British activist and she argued against
what she called the humanist gay Lobby
and as you point out there wasn't any
humanist gay lobby but once she started
complaining about it a bunch of people
got together and started one because
that sounded like a really good idea
exactly yes and it's and and it's now
you know affiliated with the that's
organization is now affiliated with
humanists UK and um I was told
they took the slogan born of Mary
because they were born out of you know
this uh this this case that was brought
against uh the magazine gay news by Mary
Whitehouse and that was in the 60s no no
it was uh yes and on it was I'm trying
to remember actually I've forgotten no
it was the 17th okay yeah 73. yeah yeah
right living it's it's early 70s memory
anyway about his mid 70s so I mean yeah
again we're still trying to compress a
lot of human history here so we've uh
we've become enlightened we've liberated
different parts of the world uh
different segments of humanity in some
sense you know if you just tell the
story of the 20th century the political
story you know there's these wars and
you know both the world wars and the
Cold War uh can we think of
fascism Nazism stalinism in some sense
as fundamentally anti-humanist movements
but in a kind of a different way because
they're sort of valorizing the state or
the system uh rather than the individual
human being yeah well I think that's
absolutely right that's exactly what
makes them anti-humanist because it's it
has the same structure in a way there's
something wrong with
um like deeply wrong not just details
that are wrong there's something
profoundly out of kills her about human
life as we find it yeah
um what's needed is a strong
authoritative other thing and that thing
might be in in communism of course it's
you know the Marxist dialectic the
dictatorship of the product area there's
a it's an abstract it's an abstraction
it's a theory that's going to
revolutionize human life and make us
into these sort of this Shining Light of
the of the post-revolutionary world
where every body is
fulfilled so nobody is alienated anymore
everybody and of course the reality
turns out to be quite the opposite of
that so yeah inevitably because it's
it's imposing a you know an abstract
idea isn't it imposing the state again
the state is what guarantees all of that
so the state is being set up as
um having an absolute authority over
individual choices I mean you can't if
you're part of a revolutionary State you
you can't just live your little
individual choices that can't be
tolerated because everything must be
subordinated to this goal and of course
in Nazism what you've got and fascism
are all kinds you've got the Nation
playing that role you've got National
Destiny
um plus you've got the figure of the
dictator so you've got Mussolini we've
got Hitler being you know sort of
playing that absolute role individual
Freedom individual choices individual
responsibility the kind of humanist
basis for Morality that relies on our
fellow feeling our empathy or our sense
of responsibility to other people all of
that goes because it's all to be
subordinated to the needs at the stage
um profoundly anti-humanistic I think
those movements so yeah how I guess we
didn't say this explicitly how crucial
is the idea of individualism to humanism
I mean I could imagine claiming that I'm
a humanist but being a humanist who uh
puts front and center some group of
human beings rather than individual
human beings yeah I individualism is
problematic concept because it's can
also be associated with this um idea of
in of individual self-assage you know
the justification of of I mean I think
it was sort of in Rand
um idea that uh the an individual who
our kind of Niche and Superman Uber
Mensch that can just research themselves
and and have everything they want it's a
kind of neoliberalism in in the market
the idea that this basically might is
right well
um definitely that kind of individualism
would would not be particularly
humanistic I think
um and individualism in itself is a very
when you sort of go back through the
centuries in history it becomes very
hard to talk about individualism it's
very modern concept that doesn't always
make a lot of sense when you're talking
about
um different historical times that when
does it really arise I think it's a sort
of a concept of the of the individual is
well it becomes a very 19th century
concept and
um liberal philosophy there are several
liberal thinkers who were deeply
humanistic because they did think about
the individual but they also thought
about it in the context of
um be having a sort of
um the well-being of all and at how out
so it's if individual people are
basically the state steps out with their
lives as much as is possible except to
prevent them harming each other so to
prevent abuses that's the role of the
state is to prevent
um anybody's Freedom being brutally
curtailed by somebody else's but within
that basically people should be able to
develop as they want to by having
running their personal lives the way
they want to as long as they don't harm
anybody else you know this is the
central idea I think of of liberalism
which is which is very humanistic so I
mean to say that all humanism is
individualistic I think it's not it's
just not quite right because it's kind
of it blurs some of the historical
developments and it also gets
dangerously mixed up with this
um rather arrogant idea of the
individual as being able to do whatever
they like which is totally inconsistent
with with the humanist idea that we
um are basically sort of morally
response possible to each other that we
have a responsibility to our the people
that we live among and not only people
but also to other animals to the rest of
the natural world to to you know the
very foundations of life
um so yeah it's contemplating it has
been so many things it ends up being
it's complicated is the answer it is
complicated but I think that I think you
put your figure on something it does
make sense to me the idea that what we
think of as Classical liberalism
emphasizes the individual and their
rights and their flourishing whereas the
humanist tradition has individuals as
very important but cares a lot about
helping other individuals I mean you
mentioned the EM Forester quote of only
connect you know it's individuals matter
but not in the sense that they matter
individually
but as you know the object of our care
well really if I had to say what is my
favorite quote from the um well I'll
tell you what actually favorite two
quotes I think from the whole of
humanist thought one is
um from Terence the the
um afro
um Roman playwright of the ancient world
who who said a very famous line of I am
human I consider nothing human alien to
me
um we're all connected the other one
that I was originally going to say was
um uh from the 19th century free thinker
Roberts T Ingersoll apparently it was
pronounced Ninja song English okay
because his enemies used to call him
injure Soul because he was injuring
people's Souls apparently by by going
around preaching as secularist
free-thinking uh message uh preaching
that's not the right word there but you
know and um and he came up with what he
called the happiness Credo it was his
belief
um about how to be happy and he said the
time to be happy is now the place to be
happy is he here he starts at happiness
is the only good the time to be happy is
now the place to be happy is here and
the way to be happy is to make others so
can't leave out that last life
yeah exactly it all goes together it's
it's it's happiness is for this world
not for some imagined Paradise
um Beyond
um it's the here and now but it's uh
yeah the path to happiness lies through
being connected to each other and loving
human being alien to us so let's just
leap up to the present day now uh we're
in a situation where okay we've in some
sense won the battles against Fascism
and stalinism and so forth maybe but I'm
not sure yeah sometimes I know I should
even as I spoke those words I was kept
bringing them back but there's a
different Frontier uh people now talk
about transhumanism and post-humanism
there's a technological Frontier
uploading ourselves into the Matrix uh
frolicking and virtual reality do you
see these technological advances as
tools to further the humanist cause or
potential challenges to them I think
that at the moment it's of course it's
all very theoretical at the moment I
mean we're dealing with
um the arrival the imminence and arrival
in many ways of with artificial
intelligence things that are not human
but uh you know you have some kind of
intelligence this is something we're
going to have to wrestle with for sure
um in relation to what it is to be a
human being and what humans need
um as opposed to What machines might
need
um but that this sort of Wilder shores
of transhumanism the idea that we will
merge with machine intelligence or with
a kind of abstract
um spiritual or intellectual mentalism
in in the universe not need bodies
anymore
um it's always yeah I find it kind of
fun and fascinating as an idea but I
think that it misses so much about what
it is to be human and this is where
humanism is there to remind us that
being human of course it's a bodily
thing but it's it's also we're connected
to our societies that we grow up in the
people that we know the people that we
live among and to all the details of of
our cultural lives as a the whole planet
you know we have this tremendous
cultural inheritance from each other
from all the things that have happened
in the past books that people have
written the art music everything else
that is that there's tremendous
humanistic realm of of human culture
um and the just the details of our
everyday lives all of that I mean it's
as if this transhumanist idea treats all
of that as being something that could
just be cast aside and then there would
be a pure human essence of some sort
that could just float about in a purely
mental realm
um as an abstraction and I think that
there's something that's is
um really sad about that I now feel I
mean I used to feel but that was quite
exciting when I used to read science
fiction I'm gonna still do read science
fiction I love it but it's it's that
particular idea is to sing like wow you
know Cosmetics Transcendent who wouldn't
want to be have a mind that's basically
almost identical with the whole universe
um and now I think well yeah but what
about all the things I love what about
reading pet drugs letters what about you
know sort of looking at
artworks what about
um just you know sort of having a cup of
tea with my wife or passing the dog and
uh I mean all of that so there's sort of
the texture of of Life the uh the
intertwined nature of our reality with
each other and with the particulars of
the planet that we live on
um is is sort of treated as dispensable
and I think that there's something
you're kind of talking again about
something rather similar to this idea
that all of the detail of
um this life is something in the old
kind of idea of the religious the telly
dedicated religious life would be that
you set aside all of that as you know
don't enjoy it don't
enjoy eating drinking listening to music
or whatever it may be because you should
always just be thinking about the
paradise that lies Beyond and you see a
very similar structure really in some of
this transhumanist dream that it's all
of that detail doesn't matter there's
going to be something better yeah I
think that's not humanist yeah I'm
extremely sympathetic here and you know
to wind things up maybe I don't even
have a question but let me just say some
things that that what you just said uh
Sparks in my brain and you can respond
to it uh because you know to be more
specific you mentioned the science
fictional ways of thinking you mentioned
in the book particularly Arthur C
Clarke's childhood's end where you know
the human beings are visited by aliens
and ultimately they all sort of
transcend into this higher realm
um and it's not that different than a
lot of ideas about joining The Matrix
and you know being free of our bodily
wants and it's not that different from
classical views of heaven right where we
get a reward in in there's words about
eternity and infinity and things like
that and what I feel about these is that
they really
neglect The crucial Central Point about
being human which is our finitude and
the struggles the embodiment that we
have in the world and just the need to
be fed and to walk and to touch and to
be sad sometimes and I I struggle myself
because I want to be open to new things
and better things and I don't know what
they would be like but I do feel like
like you just said that some of this
narrative is just glossing over what
makes us us and it wouldn't be as as
good as people are imagining I mean it
would be good in a different way perhaps
even but it would be good in a way that
is no longer recognizably human I think
that with the loss of all that
um to which as I say I I would also add
are social nature we're extremely social
animals we have
um I mean we are nothing without uh it's
very hard to imagine a life completely
separated from any kind of social
contact you wouldn't need to know where
to start with that idea of what that
would be like
um especially if you're talking about
from childhood from the beginning I mean
we're formed by our social contact
um how could if you sort of Imagine
something better that somehow leaves all
that behind you know it's there was this
um strand in medieval thinking some of
the more extreme uh theological writings
of uh of of the
um sort of well various times in
medieval writing that that wrestling
with the problem of okay you live a good
life and you go to heaven what about
your relatives and beloved ones and
children or whatever who have not had a
good life and they're going to hell how
are you supposed to feel about that
um and some some people even said well
actually it's it's fine because you'll
be so transformed when you go to heaven
that you'll be able to sort of lean over
as it were and look down on them in hell
and just watch them with total
detachments or even pleasure is if
you're just sort of you watch them ride
around in the fans of hell and you can
even take pleasure in it because you
will be so changed and I think that
really
um touches on this issue with the
transhumanist idea is that we will be so
changed that we won't miss yeah all
about you know interesting the people we
love because we're going to be you know
sort of this Transcendent thing I'm
always suspicious of of anything that
promises any kind of transcendence uh
reality well maybe then the lesson is
that whether it's uh
education or Liberation or technology
there's more need for tough like
humanism than ever before
foreign
every level of society in this and made
it as he's a bit optimistic we can be
optimistic that's okay it's the end of
the podcast is the time to be optimistic
so Sarah big well thanks so much for
being on the mindscape podcast thank you
very much indeed I've really enjoyed it
[Music]
mama